how's it going everybody it's Warren and
with Avengers endgame wrapping up the
first 11 years of the MCU and phase 3
and with phase 4 starting immediately
after with spider-man far from home
people are starting to wonder who the
next main villain is going to be in the
MCU however there is a theory going
around right now that Avengers endgame
is actually setting up the next big bad
villain for the MCU and that villain is
the one and only Galactus I'll break it
all down in this video but first if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe I'm doing a new giveaway
giving away five imax tickets if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain this
theory comes from redditor je le French
and French argues that de Knossos plan
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
many people have argued this before
asking the question well why didn't
Thanos just double the resources and the
researchers have come out and confirmed
that Thanos has snapped killed half of
all life in the universe including
animals so his snap actually reduced
resources as well which is the exact
opposite of what he is trying to do and
if we look at the noses home planet
Titan it is completely thrown off its
axis and nothing is growing there
anymore and not to mention that in
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 the Nova
Corps mentions that Gamora is the last
of her species but Thanos said that her
home planet is thriving with families
and children on it
and Gamora has mentioned that Thanos has
killed all of her people and when the
Russo brothers were asked about this
they simply said well who do you believe
Thanos or Gamora implying that one of
them is lying and since there's a lot of
things that don't really add up with fan
OSes plan I'm gonna go ahead and say
it's Thanos so the theory is made that
Marvel is actually getting us ready for
it Galactus black Disco's planet to
planet consuming the planet and it's
energy to sustain his life force and
this theory states that Thanos is
actually trying to save the universe
stripping each planet of enough life to
make them undesirable to Galactus it was
too late for his home planet Titan which
is why it's how it is now completely
barren and thrown off its axis
but he knows Galactus is out there and
is coming which is why he is now cursed
with knowledge this theory has a lot of
merit to it
if you want the next main villain to be
bigger and badder than Thanos Galactus
is the candidate and with the Disney Fox
deal officially done Disney can now use
Galactus the Silver Surfer and the
Fantastic Four it's definitely exciting
to think about and the theory definitely
has its merits however there are some
flaws as well
the main one being Y with a nose lie why
wouldn't he warn the universe about
Galactus and since he collected all of
the Infinity stones and had the Infinity
Gauntlet why didn't he just snap him out
of existence but perhaps in the MCU you
can't snap cosmic entities out of
existence but maybe after Avengers
endgame Galactus knows everything that
went down and starts to head to earth
Kevin Feige stated that nobody could
work on anything related to the Fox
characters until the deal was officially
done but since the deal has taken a
couple of years to complete Marvel has
been prepping us for the arrival of
Galactus but let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments down
below it may not be that plausible but
it sure would be very exciting to see
Galactus enter the MCU and of course be
sure to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers in game and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]